Поки у Європі з кожним днем фіксують дедалі менше нових інфекцій Covid-19,
у країнах Латинської Америки, де нині початок зими,
навпаки епідемія у самому розпалі.
Німецькі епідеміологи виходять з того, що восени і в ЄС
кількість спалахів коронавірусної інфекції може різко зрости,
коли знову більше людей перебуватимуть у закритих приміщеннях.
Утім, не обов'язково захворюваність сягне таких масштабів, як цієї весни.
Відомий вірусолог з Бонна Гендрік Штреек переконаний,
що друга хвиля епідемії Німеччині не загрожує.
Водночас інший німецький знавець вірусів, Крістіан Дростен
з берлінської кліники "Шаріте" висловлюється обережніше.
На його думку, "існує теоретична можливість уникнути другої хвилі епідемії".
Спокій німецьким експертам вселяє насамперед те,
що німці загалом чемно дотримуються правил гігієни і соціальної дистанції.
Завдяки послабленню локдауну ми рухаємося у напрямку нормалізації ситуації.
А нормалізація означає також, що ризик інфекцій, звісно, знову зростає.
Водночас я бачу дієвість певних заходів.
Наприклад, того, що люди носять маски в транспорті та у магазинах.
Це означає, що все вже не так, як раніше.
Громадяни вже у своїй більшості дбають про соціальну дистанцію та носять маски.
Завдяки такій суміші з пом'якшення карантину та добровільного дотримання правил,
які засвідчили свою ефективність,
ми маємо відносно сприятливу ситуацію.
Проте поки важко спрогнозувати, що переважить:
збільшення кількості інфекцій від пом'якшень
чи зменшення від носіння масок та тримання відстані.
У прогнозах німецьких вірусологів про ймовірність "другої хвилі" епідемії
велику роль відіграє теорія про "суперпоширювачів".
Згідно з нею, окремі інфіковані (їх відносно мало)
мають підвищену заразність -
вони передають вірус особливо великій кількості осіб.
А ще вони кажуть про таке явище як "супер-поширення",
коли в певних ситуаціях заражається надзвичайно багато осіб.
Приклад - знамените карнавальне засідання у Гайнсбергу в Західній Німеччині.
Дослідження показало, що практично всі, хто заразився "ковідом"
на цьому засіданні, мали симптоми хвороби.
А ті, хто інфікувався не на цих посиденьках, частіше хворіли без симптомів.
Люди святкували карнавал і внаслідок цих розваг сталося "суперпоширення" -
вірусохопив значну кількість людей.
Висновок науковців: підвищена концентрація вірусу
сприяє важчому протіканню хвороби.
Розгадка "суперпоширення" могла б стати ключем
до приборкання ковід-пандемії, каже Дірк Брокманн.
Інститут Роберта Коха рекомендує для уникнення другої хвилі
громадянам суворо дотримуватися перевірених заходів:
На мою думку, продовжують позитивно впливати на ситуацію такі заходи,
як носіння масок у особливих ситуаціях: під час шопінгу, в метрополітені.
Також для вгамування епідемії потрібно, аби не створювалися ситуації,
коли одна людина може заразити дуже багато інших.
Важливо проводити дуже багато тестувань, аби дедалі краще розуміти,
за яких, власне, обставин відбувається підвищене зараження -
так зване "суперпоширення".
Як припускає вірусолог з Бонна Гендрік Штреек,
неявних випадків інфікування коронавірусом
приблизно у десять разів більше, ніж підтверджених тестами.
За його оцінками, у Німеччині насправді
інфікувалися вже близько 2 мільйонів людей.
Це означає, що у решти 80 мільйонів німців імунітету досі немає.
І без вакцини казати пандемії "відбій" зарано.
Навіть із низьким рівнем інфекцій - на щастя, у даний момент
ми маємо чітко усвідомлювати, що пандемія ще не минула.
Вона взята під контроль, але вірус ще існує.
У нас немає вакцини, ми досі не маємо ліків,
Таким чином, особливо зараз, коли ми можемо дозволити собі більше
і коли соціальне життя у деяких сферах вже відновилося,
ми мусимо бути ще більш пильними.
Вірусологи вимагають: концерти і фестивалі, вистави у театрах,
перегляд матчів на стадіонах та інші масові заходи
повинні залишатися під забороною.
Лише в такому разі можна сподіватися уникнути другої хвилі коронавірусу.